i am 30.
30 years old do you have any children i
have two and i also have custody of my
niece
okay so three kids live with you yep
okay hello to your kids
um thirteen three and then my niece is
nine thirteen three and nine
thirteen your your children do they have
the same dad no
was you ever married
no
why are you not with the three-year-old
dad
so we have the same birthday and you can
ask i hope it's not my wi-fi
i think no girl i apologize i think it's
mine okay all right so let's try it
again so why are you not with a
three-year-old dad
um i'll be totally honest and
transparent so my youngest daughter is a
one-night stand baby
we co-parent well
we just didn't take it anywhere after
after the one-night stand um
yeah like y'all don't wear condoms in
one night stands
i mean i can explain to you the story if
you wanna
i wanna hear it
okay so i was in a relationship with a
guy for seven years that was my longest
relationship
um we broke up and
i let loose and yeah i definitely should
have
used protection but it was my birthday
it was his birthday we was drunk
and yeah we made a baby
yeah that's hilarious yeah what do we
think of um that broken women
broken society oh wait also one thing
one quick thing guys we're turning the
chat on to members only so become a
member if you want to be a part of the
chat anyways go ahead
um
these women like this one night stand
babies because it was her birthday are
raising the next generation
and and and i'm sure
women like that are not an isolated case
there are many
women like that specifically in america
um
where there are children being raised
by women who are so frivolous
with
their vaginas let's say right that they
give it to any and everyone and now
they've got children to race because of
it what do we think about
[Laughter]
yeah but but like i said
women decide who they have children with
we spoke about it already
it's the women that are deciding to have
these children
because it's a bigger risk for them it's
a big role whenever it's a bigger risk
for you you have to exercise more risk
management because you're the one who
could end up in a much more negative
situation
and we have and we have more options
when it comes to preventing that sort of
stuff than men do yes definitely i feel
like that
the story i feel like the story of that
was
probably not representing a large number
of women
and remember that her child is not
representing a large number of children
remember the video before right yeah
and then you see this one yeah that's
two videos two videos but how i'm saying
if you go on kendrick's show
no it's ever
i try to get on kendra they never let me
on yeah i feel like
i feel like i would kill that show
but but no um no they literally are
always like that like some people that
call into that show oh okay i say so
it's a it's a place like that i don't i
don't i don't think it's the majority of
women but i think there's a large
minority yeah that like a substantial
minority of women that are delusional
yeah i mean there's a large minor
there's a large amount of just
general delusional people i just feel
like this is not
that video and that video and that tv
show that is specifically for those
videos no that's just videos that you've
seen and i don't think it represents
loads of
because i don't i don't see men calling
into shows and demanding victoria's
secret models like i just don't see it i
see women demanding six figure guys tall
guys whatever but i don't see girls
or guys calling into shows and saying i
need a model yeah you just get laughed
at he'll he just says like yeah if she's
okay not fat wait that's enough no kids
what a question so someone's calling
into that show for a man
yeah it's it's like a imagination
yeah yeah go ahead go ahead
okay so turn on your camera come on come
on
[Applause]
uh oh
yeah give it a sec
i'll i'll add it on okay okay this
i'll explain all right we'll watch the
second part of it and then i'll add my
point okay let's watch the second part
cool um from 10 15 10 15.
yeah from 10 15.
i just
yeah i want to get your guys views on
this where is it
okay 10 15. yeah
let's have a look because you said was
she calling that shoulders for a man
we saw a guy who's that in the
background
who's that in the background speak you
can talk you've been talking to me all
the time i told you or why
that's the guy you have sex with today
so you so the guy you have sex with
today
is in your house and you're on my show
looking for a new guy
i'm on my i'm on your show to tell you
that i'm single and if you know i find
it on my show to look for a new guy
because that's what this show is about
so so
i'm on the show just to put myself out
there yes yeah you're on this you're on
the show to meet a new guy that's what
the show is about let's be clear okay
we're not going to circle around the
fact of the show right you come on the
show to me whomever if you're into women
you're intimate so
you want to meet a guy
while you have the guy you slept with in
your house
what kind of quality man you think is
gonna hit you up
i'm just being honest i mean i mean i'm
being honest too what kind of quality
man you think is gonna hit you up yeah i
don't know you tell me kendra not one
okay
a me and i might have that a man will
hit you up that want to have sex with
you but not a man that's gonna take you
serious
not absolutely not there is no man
that's watching this right now a quality
man that's gonna hit you up and take you
serious with the guy you slept with this
morning in the background while you on
this show and if that's what you desired
and that's what you desire it's your
life but you're gonna have to own up to
the fact that you got a lot of stuff to
get together very trifling if you want
this and if you wanna if you wanna
attract the trifling guy they're so big
give them your instagram page or your
facebook page so i just
i think that's hilarious i just hope she
has that same kind of comedic energy if
you know or let's say when she ends up
like being really alone um and a lot
older with like you know boxed wine and
cats you know
but what but for me
i need to understand the psychology
i need to understand the psychology
that makes you think that you can call a
dating show
yeah with the with the person that
you've just had sex with in your house
looking for another person because i've
i'll say this i don't think a man would
do that
i don't think a man would call a dating
show
with the woman walking around naked in
the background that he just had sex with
saying yeah i'm saying i'm saying i want
to get another girl i don't think men
would do that i think they would do that
for their lads
they'd go be like yeah i've got a girl
but i'm you know yeah
but like are men really going like
welcome dating shows because the thing
is going on a dating show doesn't always
mean you want to go on a date a lot of
the time you just want attention so do
you think she's actually looking for a
man i don't think she was i kind of got
the feeling she was just trying to go
viral and then she was like
just to see what's out there you know i
would actually i would actually magnify
that to a on a bigger scale i don't
think a lot of girls actually want to
date i think they just want attention as
well you know and i'm not saying there's
anything wrong with that i'm just saying
it is what it is you know like if you
want to if you just want attention
that's fine but if you're going to
masquerade that as like you want to date
and find a nice guy then
do you think that's a bit selfish when
you have kids to do that